TO PUT A KINK IN THEIR PLANS AN
PLAYING WITH SUTER.
SUTER WELL OVER A THOUSAN FOR
19 STRAIGHT
BEEN ON FIRE.
>> NOW, KELLER HAS IT.
AND TRY TO
MOVE IT UP THEHIT.
PUCK PLAYED BACK TO CENTER AND
MOVES IT A
CHANGE.
>> AND STRALMAN. OW GET SOME H
RITCHIE.
CLAYTON KELLER RIP THAT ON THE
BACKHAND, SO MUCH SPEED HE'LL PT
ALONG, GOSTISBEHE BOYD.
>> AND THE COYOTES WERE
THERE TO TAKE THE PERIOD FOR THE
COYOTES.   FRONT.
BLOCKED BY CHYCHRUN A A
AND LEADING THE CHARGE AND  SPI
PAVELSKI IN FRONT
DOWN THE B BATTLE.
THEY GET THE PUCK T T IMAGINE T
ADDRESSED IN THE LOCKER ROOM
BETWEEN TRYING TO PUSH IT ALONG
HE
HASN RIGHT PAD AND
KICKS IT OFF ONCE AGAIN.
TO JUMP UP AND THIS THIRDS ANDE
RESCUE.
>> ARIZONA A WRISTER TOWARD THE
NET.
BROKEN PAVELSKI
OPPORTUNITY IN ALL ALO BOTH TEA
BIG HIT HEY LONG THE BOARD THIS
TIME.
AND THAT  EVERYTHING GOING
TO THE NET AND ROBERTSON BLOWS
IT THROUHER CHANCE, ROBERTSON.
WEKLINGBERG.
HARLEY COMES IN.   OF THIS PUCK
THE OTHER WAY, SCHMALTZD THERE